aujourd'hui issu des conseils municipaux
demain les conseillers communautaires
devraient être élus au suffrage
universel direct par le système dit du
fléchage aux élections municipales de
2014 les électeurs découvriront ce
processus sur les bulletins de vote
seront mentionnés les candidats aptes à
siéger au Conseil Communautaire leur
nombre est fixé en fonction du poids
démographique de leur ville ça va
conférer au Conseil Communautaire une
légitimité supérieure hein les élus
communautaires ne seront plus des élus
par des élus mais seront élu directement
par les citoyens bon euh ce qui de
surcroix conférera aussi une certaine
autonomie au conseil communautaire qui
ne sera plus placé sous la stricte
dépendance des conseils municipaux ce
système de fléchage est déjà pratiqué à
Paris Lyon et Marseille aux élections
municipales de 2014 cette réforme
permettra aussi de faire des économies
en moyenne l'organisation d'un scrutin
sur le plan national en
France coûte aux environs de 120 à 150
millions d'euros bon donc là on procède
à deux scrutins en un seul les élections
municipales d'un côté les élections
communautaires de l'autre regroupé au
sein d'un seul et même processus
électoral voilà donc c'est plutôt
positif dans l'ensemble regrouper les
deux scrutins est aussi une façon de
profiter de la participation toujours
très forte des électeurs à l'élection
municipal juste derrière les
présidentielles et d'assoir donc la
légitimité des conseillers
communautaires à 5 ans en Yveline 42
élus siègent dans cette assemblée issue
des SEP communes de la Communauté
d'agglomération